si fue un momento muy emotivo que miles
y miles de personas no solamente
británicos sino de todo el mundo
llevaban esperando para poder compartir
aquí en las afueras del palacio de
buckingham miles llegaron pese a la
lluvia querían darle el último adiós a
isabel segunda la reina de miles y miles
de personas alrededor del mundo la única
que conocemos en las últimas
generaciones y que no solamente ha sido
un símbolo de la unidad británica pero
muchos la ven como una abuela así que
fue un momento muy emotivo en el momento
exacto en que el féretro llegó aquí a
las afueras de palacio de buckingham y
cruzó esas puertas doradas hubo un
aplauso generalizado algunas personas
lloraron trajeron flores pude hablar con
una familia de australia que él ha visto
no solamente como la jefe del como wells
esa comunidad de países que va desde
aquí de inglaterra a territorios en el
caribe que también integra a australia
nueva zelanda pudieron entonces
presentar esos sentidos homenajes a la
reina isabel segunda y decían que la
reina fue fundamental por supuesto para
la unidad del commonwealth pero sobre
todo la veían como una abuela luego el
cuerpo fue llevado al bowling del
palacio de bukingham y se le presentó
una pequeña ceremonia liderada por el
rey carlos tercero su esposa la reina
consorte camila también estudiaron el
príncipe de gales william y la princesa
de gales kate así como harry y megan en
las últimas horas se conoció un emotivo
y ximo mensaje de la princesa anna la
única hija mujer de la reina isabel que
dijo que tuvo la suerte de compartir las
últimas 24 horas de su vida con la reina
isabel y que la acompañó en sus dos
últimos viajes porque fue ella la única
integrante de la familia real que viajó
en ese jet de la fuerza armada real
británica desde edimburgo hasta aquí
hasta londres
y louisa mañana se podrá velar ya isabel
segunda en su cámara ardiente en el
parlamento cuáles serán los actos de
traslado del féretro y sede cuando desde
cuándo podrán entrar el público a hablar
la
les cuento que desde las primeras horas
de esta mañana ya hay personas agolpadas
a lo largo y ancho de demos esa avenida
que ustedes seguramente tienen presente
porque es la avenida roja larga que
termina en el palacio de buckingham ya
hay personas acampando porque quieren
ser los primeros en presenciar ese
momento histórico el cortejo fúnebre
será impresionante liderado por las
fuerzas militares y todos los soldados
pertenecientes al batallón del rey al
batallón de la reina empezará este
traslado a las 2 y 22 de la tarde -hora
local- en punto el cuerpo de isabel
segunda será transportada en un carruaje
especial que será llevado por seis
caballos el recorrido tardará alrededor
de 40 minutos por las calles principales
del centro de londres y será llevado
hasta el parlamento británico donde en
la cámara ardiente ubicada en el
westminster hall será velada la reina se
abrirán las puertas a la alrededor de
las 5 y 30 hora local- se permitirá
visitar a las reinas cuatro horas del
día por cuatro días las medidas de
seguridad son bien extremas como tipo
aeropuerto se ha pedido a las personas
que no lleven maletas grandes que no
vayan niños no pueden tomar fotos no
pueden llevar flores y que ese respeto
ese tributo personal que van a poder
rendir al ataúd de la reina sea lo más
rápido posible para permitir que el
mayor número de personas pueda ingresar
se prevé que asistirán entre setecientos
cincuenta mil personas y un millón pero
lo cierto es que viendo la cantidad de
personas que han venido a las afueras
del palacio de buckingham no sabremos en
realidad cuántas personas podrán asistir
si luisa y rápidamente serán también
numerosos los mandatarios y miembros de
otras familias reales que acudan a
despedir a la monarca tenemos ya
confirmaciones oficiales sobre quién
acudirá y cuál será el protocolo
será el evento logístico y de seguridad
más grande que haya presenciado el reino
unido ya uno de los asistentes al
presidente de los eeuu joe biden y su
esposa jill se espera que la mayoría de
presidentes y jefes de estado de los
países europeos asistan también los
primeros ministros de los países del
commonwealth de américa latina'
confirmado el presidente de brasilia el
bolsonaro también lo ha hecho el rey
emérito de españa el rey felipe en la
reina letizia de españa también el rey
de mónaco y otros integrantes de las
familias reales como los reyes de
bélgica